saffron I understand that you and your
family your sisters they all rallied
around your grandparents when they were
trying to navigate the internet for the
first few times what year was that and
what was it like watching them I think
it was 2009 or my grandparents learned
to use the internet they're both about
80 years old and their main reason for
wanting to get online was we have
relatives that live in Ireland we have a
younger cousin he's about five years old
and they were upset that they weren't
there seeing him grow up so they decided
to get online so that they could skype
with him every day so they started you
know skyping with him while he ate his
dinner at night my uncle would bring his
iphone to soccer games to piano lessons
so they could watch him as he was
growing up via Skype and it was just
incredible for them to be able to do
that what were some of their fears at
first and what were some of the things
that delighted them aside from being
able to see someone face to face almost
through a computer screen I think with
most seniors it's scary getting online
especially if you've never used a
computer before a lot of them are afraid
they're going to press a button that
breaks the entire computer and then you
know it's done or they get stuck
something freezes or something's not
working and they they're too afraid to
figure out how to fix it so it just sits
there for weeks and weeks so those are
some of the obstacles but yeah the the
ability to connect with family even with
family that doesn't live that far away I
mean we live an hour away from our
grandparents but having them on Facebook
and Skype they were just able to look
more deeply into our lives and it made
us a lot closer with them
you